máximo leakage and I covered the basic
definition the basic theorem variations
on it
comparison with mutual information and
Maxima Lika and different for privacy
etc I did not really say much about
mechanisms so I'm gonna take maybe two
minutes minutes maybe and talk a bit
about mechanisms so we've tried applying
this in a few different contexts one
kind of meta theorem if you will that
come that's come out is that the metric
tends to favor quantization or say
adding adding noise it's not an absolute
statement okay it's not always the case
that's that's the way to go but we have
you know various theorems that in
certain situations is what you want to
do so I guess I put up one kind of
trivial example of that yesterday of
them do a slightly less trivial example
right now so
it's just kind of an optimal mechanisms
so let's consider minimizing choosing P
Y given X to minimize the leakage
subject to an average cost constraint
we're given the distribution for ax so
the you know the leakage itself is kind
of invariant to the distribution for X
but we might have two costs obviously
the description for X then appears
suppose we're given that suppose were
given a cost function just take X symbol
and a Y symbol and we map that to a cost
and it will allow infinite costs and
then I can imagine minimizing the
leakage over all mechanisms so I guess
we're fixing the y alphabet here as well
so think about the X alphabet has fixed
the y alphabet is fixed that's made
attempted a calligraphic
so the two alphabets are fixed and the
marginal for X is fixed and were given a
cost function and now I can imagine
trying to minimize the the leakage from
X to Y so the constraint say on the
average cost
all right so that's a problem you can
write down its kind of convenient or
computational purposes to eliminate the
login here so this has an implicit log
so we use this we use the computable
characterization right here for this so
it's helpful to eliminate the log so
I'll just take through the power that
okay and then as you're minimizing over
the mechanism of sum over Y X over X
let's put this full support which PC
don't need that that condition to be
carried along this okay so this you can
write as an LP
their program all you do is kind of
define extra variables that capture the
column sum and then it's all linear and
those in those variables okay so you
know in general I guess you'd stop there
and say okay that's the that's the
problem you know given all this stuff
you beat the LP and that's that we we've
tried applying this in some situations
like the RSA decryption side-channel I
mentioned yesterday so you know the
decryption takes a certain amount of
time you want to kind of delay it
possibly randomly a certain amount of
extra time before you announce the
result to make it hard to for an
adversary to conduct these kind of
timing attacks and when apprehension we
had about playing this was all there is
that my computer architecture cogs want
to measure X it like almost like an
instruction level granularity and so the
alphabet for X ends up being really big
Hawaiian's are being really big so you
can solve this LP in principle the LP is
huge you know it might may or may not
run in a reasonable at a time if it does
you've got this huge py given X matrix
you've got to work with you got to store
that you have to kind of you know
implement the the randomness intrinsic
in it you know and as you're every time
you do the RSA decryption so it's not
clear this is really going to work we
solve this LP in some examples and found
ahead some structure to it in fact it
looked like every example we ran the py
given X was always a mixture of a most
two deterministic py given X matrices
and so we tried to show that we were
able to show it although it turns out
that there's structure in our cost
matrix that was cropping up and that
structure is important so
let me show you the structure that was
cropping up in our cost so the cost
function reviews a matrix okay so the X
are the rows the Y the columns this okay
so an XY entry just tells you the cost
if the you know the true computation
time was X and you announce that you
know a time Y then what's the cost so
the the cost matrix that we had had a
certain property to it it has infinities
in our case like you know the Y has to
be grading equal to X so it's upper
triangle and you have infinities beneath
it
more generally I'm just gonna impose the
constraint that if any one entry is
infinity then everything to the left and
everything below is infinity so the
infinities kind of form a staircase like
this
is that some kind of causality section
yeah you can think of it that way yeah
like why it has to be equal to X yeah in
this case you're timing things right
yeah
X X is the so like this you know
everyone agrees on x 0 and the
capitation starts X is the actual
completion time and Y is the time when
we announce the result so I has to be at
least X which is what gives us these
yeah and then also the the finite
entries are non decreasing along the
rows
increase in that direction so you know
in the actual completion time example
you'd have infinities you know below the
diagonal and then it's hopeless after
that he may have zeros you know on the
diagonal and then one on the super
diagonal and and so on right so the cost
increases the more you delay Y for a
given forgiving X okay so we'll call
this staircase increasing is for lack of
a better name across the matrix is
called staircase increasing if it has
this structure to it so if any one
entries infinity everything the left and
below is infinity and then the finite
values are non decreasing along the rows
no decreasing along the rows and Finity
to have two for mr. K's that's it yeah
pretty pretty good application this what
are the range of like looks like the
fastest deeper you know what's the
fastest one of the slowest ones so they
get a sense if I just what it has
pensively yeah terribly leaky is it yeah
I don't I don't know numbers off time
they had we've been playing some small
examples like negative two different sir
is it like
yeah I mean so we've been playing with
some small examples like 16-bit key
because then we can just like exhaust
all the keys and measure all the
possible thing for that you don't get
like a huge you know discrepancy between
the worst case and the fastest one in
the shortest one but is there and
there's a reason why the computation has
done you know the results announced when
it's done you know did it get away
is it the average case is better than
the worst case but if you grow with the
number of keys I don't know how that
scales I mean it's the size of the key
grows it couldn't that that gap could
open up but yeah it's a good question
okay so okay so the theorem is
for this problem for this LP okay if the
cost matrix has this structure so it
depends so you know we we started with
like a 16-bit key example and you know
then I think the the size of X&Y we're
like in the hundreds or thousands or
something but then when when you have
like realistic size keys in this example
then you know you have blows up to the
alphabet size with like hundreds of
thousands into Millions is what we
estimated mean you can't exhaust all the
keys and even check it so you're you're
kind of estimating but big you're big
enough that like the py given X matrix
you can't really store even if you solve
it right but if there's some structure
though that we can we can use ok so the
theorem is if the cost function is
staircase increasing
and the lagrangian of this is minimized
by deterministic mechanisms
leakage or the leakage without the log
factor plus lambda times expected cost
right I got this
is minimized by deterministic you like
given X
so first I'm not gonna go through the
proof of this first let me just say a
word about the the implications of this
this is we're happy to have this because
it implies various useful things for us
for one thing it means that we have to
store the py given X object is really
like a 1d structure rather than a 2d
structure right for each you know for
each X you just gonna store which Y it
it maps to you don't have to produce
randomness in your mechanism obviously
it's a terminus of scheme right you're
not prone to averaging attacks because
it's dramatic scheme right so yeah this
kind of buys you a lot and it's not
something we forced ahead of time it's
nice to have it terminus of schemes and
that just falls out of the math it's
what it wants you to do we don't force
it uh priori our proof of this is like a
lot more complicate and I thought it
would be like when we first started
seeing this that like the term stick
mechanisms were copying out of this LP I
thought well like if it's if it's true
that deterministic mechanisms are
optimal it should be easy to show
because like for this for this LP here
like there's an implicit constraint on
py given acts as a public matrix right
so the the you know the extreme points
of that feasible set sorry deterministic
mechanisms court are extreme points of
that feasible set and certainly like a
stream points you know should achieve
the you know should be one extreme
points would be optimal right so it's
like you maybe kind of argue olp extreme
points should kind of work out our proof
is you know mark complicating that the
reason is that we have to argue that
there are other extreme points that are
not deterministic it's kind of all the
work is so we have this elaborate mass
moving procedure given a py given X we
kind of move mass you know along certain
row is in certain ways simultaneously to
make it more deterministic we happen off
function that captures how the term
stick it is a V argue is increasing and
so on and yeah X how can this be private
mr. mystic I'm skipping over that yeah
so we showed separately that under this
formulation that there's no advantage to
having why you have a larger alphabet
than X
Oh so you're using the fact that they
collide into it's like injection of some
kind so that see why you don't actually
know which acts led to it even though
it's different that's a that's it yeah
okay I'm sorry I was answering a
different question yeah I mean that the
py given X that you get you know he's
gonna look like it sort of I got right X
there's a terrific Y that you all yes y
must have a smaller alphabet otherwise
if I see you why I know exactly which s
next right yeah yeah yeah just looking
at the matrix is corresponding to
something like well I'm gonna just
release things in batches every once
I've accumulated enough events I'm gonna
I mean it's a one-shot thing we're not
accumulating events exactly yeah so in
my mind this is basically a clinic what
information do we call quantizer is
essentially what what happened so like
your py given X I'll draw it down here
your py given X you have essentially
like a set of allowable Y's right and
then you know your mechanism is gonna
have to have zeros where there are
infinities and so given any Rho given
any X all you do is kind of map it to
the the y that's allowable that gives it
the lowest cost so you end up with
mechanisms that kind of do draw this
very well the interesting phenomenon
here is that even though you're allowing
arbitrary kinds of randomization yeah so
it's our but really you
nevertheless the best thing to do is to
is to discretize mr. right coronary are
strong with you so if you take away the
expectation on your cost
this will always be true and that's sort
of what we showed yesterday all max was
including max meaning if you don't have
an expectation we have a hard constraint
on every X Y this is always the answer
okay so you're saying if if this is not
expectation but if it's like for all for
all X Y like that then by always true
you mean you don't need this assumption
anymore okay
[Music]
I've been interpreted as like I'm
leaking H of whatever that partition is
yes about the key what's H no it's just
log of the number
the uniform distribution on keys right
then then I would like it's a total
probability that I delay one second
versus two seconds versus three pianos
was it one two three four mm-hmm-hmm
distribution seconds I'm gonna learn
something about the percent of the keys
so yeah I mean what is the leakage it's
log of the number of different values
you have here like oh is it the same
over a range of give X's or you end up
getting different good question I mean
it's their only finally many of these
things so it has to be insensitive on
some level right so I mean I saw after
one second I literally know that it came
out of this XO that X so that's my
uncertainty right man sorry you know the
smallest set every time I see you know
yeah I mean you know a priori it could
be any X and then you observe lie and
you know it's one of those that's true
but I mean this is saying like that's
that form of muddying you know X is
preferable to one where you try to like
say add noise do that to add a geometric
or something to it
sorry the output distribution uniform
not independent px here to me that you
would then say oh you
you know two bits in this case if the
output distribution say you know it's
not uniform well okay I mean it goes
back to so we've we look at the I sum up
all the probabilities of all the X's
corresponding to the to one value of y
guessing weather-wise uniform no it's
not in general and I guess your question
kind of amounts to like why do I
formulated this way why don't I put
mutual information here yeah okay so you
know if I mean if if we adopt this you
know notion as the measure of leakage
then we'd say you yeah you look exactly
two bits from X to Y the key is one
particular s okay so you know the
probability that the adversary can guess
s after observing this is upper bounded
by yeah the key is not X it's true the
key is the time the key is the actual
execution time so I'm sorry X is the
actual execution time it's not the key
suppressing all functions and therefore
you're suppressing this s and the most
you can leak is really two bits right
yeah I mean there exists an S that it is
like four dogs exactly you know four
times easier to guess correctly than it
was before that made me not equal your
key actually kind of does in this case
with the keys uniform and X's in terms
of function of it but its last lecture
okay so anyway our proof of this is you
know more complicated than you might
think in defense of our proof I'll just
mention that this is some assumption
like this is necessary so you can't
delete this and so you can check that
this is this conclusion is false if you
have a simple circulant cost matrix like
that it's then it will find it it'll
settle on a random scheme out of jersey
one so you know any any improved proof
that someone has it has to use something
like this structure and it is not just a
matter of saying oh LP you know
releasing you know I mean see
causality is a problem here bit like
yeah if it were equally problematic for
me to release early as it is to release
late then like you know under if under
estimating and over estimating to have
the same cause would would you get a
different structure if it was cementery
uh so like if it was symmetric and tow
plaits you're asking is the theorem hold
if C is symmetric and tow puts that the
question yeah we call the supers
diagonals are like oh yeah
yeah I mean that guys that's taupe it's
not symmetric the one and twos are flip
yeah I agree
yeah I don't know I don't know all right
so last point is you can just compare
this will you get with other metrics
so let's suppose our cost matrix is like
a four by four example with that
structure sorry just theorem you still
have to assume that why it's a small
alphabet right oh it's not true is that
you could you could do it with an
enlarged really wait but then given why
oh it's just you don't care then because
then give it Y you can perfectly
construct X every time right I think you
don't need it well no I mean it's this
is gonna try to minimize leakage it
depends on lambda of course but I mean
part of the goal here is to minimize the
leakage so yeah I mean you could map if
YX might have a same alphabet you could
map X to Y is the identity py given X so
that's a feasible point it's not gonna
score well here I guess it would score
well there so now it's yeah anything is
allowed I mean it's a baked into here
with the infinities basically is
captured what's allowed there so yeah
I'm a castle and it was really really
big then the you know this scheme would
find the identity matrix repiy why I
gave an X and that would you know that
would make this big but you don't care
because it's all about minimizing the
cost
okay everyone was done so suppose you
wanna minimize the cost
subject to
[Music]
the next leakage being less than equal
to one bit or in place of this you could
do mutual information this is the one or
in place of this we could do local
differential privacy forms of the same
problem wasn't allowed to leak one I've
kind of flipped it around here the the
objective and the constraint
so under maximal leakage the optimal
mechanism for this cost matrix and this
leakage constraint that's 4x4
zero consistent with that that week's
log of two bits of information
yeah py given X
we ought to be up or diet you know our
poor triangular right and it's just a
dense matrix there's just stuff just
numbers you know numbers between 0 & 1
you know full randomizing things so this
is a lot easier to implement than that
right there you got to store the whole
matrix you have to implement you know
real randomness when you run it
local differential privacy
so for a local defense your privacy
there exist one mechanism that gives you
a finite cost and finite leakage I just
say wait everything you know delay
everything until the worst case time and
then yeah cuz the causality constraint
right so if you try to move a little bit
of mass from here you know - laughs -
try get your costs down you got to have
a one here otherwise the leakage blows
up to infinity and the causality
prevents you from doing that so for this
particular application like local to
venture privacy he really gives you no
trade off at all there's only like one
you know allowable solution and that's
it these ones at least allow you to kind
of trade off the - but this one's
arguably easier to argue maximally cuz
you know caption what you care about in
this application but you know this is
added bonus okay
is there what the mechanism turns out to
have a simple form yeah
all right it might be very good yeah so
you can leverage this a bit so if you
want if you want the trade off like
between the cost and the leakage you
know now this thing is gonna be you know
piecewise linear and the King points
would only be it integer values of the
exponentiated leakage so you'll need to
solve at those points first of all and
you also know that you only really care
about deterministic mechanisms so we
have studied like greedy algorithms that
kind of start with this and then it
looked for like what's the single best
column to add to get my cost down and
then given that column what's the single
best column to add to that and so on and
so you can kind of build up schemes that
way and you know it's sub modular thing
and so you can get like a 1 / II
guarantee compared to using the LPE like
some reasonable polynomial time
you just run the LP like N squared okay
just you know yeah you know if I'm sure
a release point at time T and I know
their work a release points before that
I can separately solve the two
optimization problem I don't really have
to write there's like a you know
recursive structure to this problem
[Music]
classic not dynamic program out like
electrical engineers call dynamic
program what computer scientist is a
difference okay